I'm Jim this is one day built with the
guardians of the galaxy movie coming out
I thought it'd be fun to build a
star-lord mask kind of staining the
theme of it being cheap and easy
materials you can find everything you
can find it like your local dollar store
or hardware store hobby shop I'm going
to go over some of the core materials
that we're going to use and then we'll
to start building and see what happens
all right well these are some of the
materials we're going to use eyes are
our base kind of core materials
materials you might use my vary a little
bit but the base for this whole thing is
going to be this Iron Man mask now I
actually found this at a 5 below which
is kind of like a dollar store but
everything's 5 bucks or less this was
like four or five dollars there's like a
bin of them I bought a bunch of them
went to a dollar store found this
child's helmet this will actually be
like the back of the helmet and I think
we'll probably use this for the eyes and
stuff other parts are just going to be
kind of random PVC pieces it's a plastic
aluminum tubing I usually keep a bin of
just kind of miscellaneous parts you can
go to the hardware store and buy some of
these pieces like I said I'm not a hard
% sure where I'm going to use yet but
some various pieces of PVC tubing and
different cool looking fittings and
stuff also I want the eyes to light up
in the mask kind of like it does in the
movie without getting too complicated so
again at a dollar store I went bought
this child's bracelet yeah school lights
up it's like 50 cents or something well
the probably the biggest helper your
your kind of toolbox is what I use is
plastic weld it's a two-part epoxy putty
like a plumber's putty but when you wet
your hands it actually becomes really
easy kind of I'm going to manipulate it
a little bit easier lasts a little bit
longer and you can smooth it really nice
with your fingers now let's just start
building and see what happens
you
all right
all right so it's coming along it's um
it's it's kind of starting to take shape
now I just kind of glued these with a
hot glue gun just sort of temporarily
just to see how it kind of all looks
before I apply any adhesive or putty in
any of the other spots there but yeah
that's taking seeds yeah it's starting
to look a little similar I'm just going
to use these aluminum tubes I can find
these at basically any hobby store Hobby
Lobby or Michaels or any model building
store generally usually get a package of
them in various diameters and lengths or
you can buy them individually pretty
inexpensive they're easy to cut and yeah
I mean a great for having a little
piping and tubing stuff come out she
worked great LT looks like you can also
probably use aluminum wire to line all
the elements and stuff like that
probably work just as good but yeah
that's it so far
keep blowing you know plugging along I
think next we're going to cut the kid's
helmet and add that to the back of the
helmet kind of tie it all in yeah
you
all right well after about 10 hours of
work this is what we're left with the
star lowered mask all in all turned out
pretty well I thought it looks pretty
close to the one that's in the movie
considering we started off with this and
want to put this not too bad a few
things that would have liked to have
done I would have liked to finish some
of the detailing on the back of the
helmet just didn't happen and then I
kind of cheated in some of the areas
like the I just glued some metallic wall
anchors for the detailing there and the
faceplate actually I never sculpted it's
just a piece of plastic that I cut into
the shape and covered with a woman 'im
tape and then kind of penned in the
details but actually that worked pretty
good turn the lights on yeah it actually
fits pretty good it's pretty snug and
yeah that's it you you too can be
star-lord if you want to do it for
Halloween or a cosplay or something no
hope you found this helpful or
entertaining but but ya can go out and
make your own or ah probably wait a
couple of weeks and buy one and I get
boys doors
I'm sure won't be long before I'll be
star-lord Mastan all the costume shops
and toy stores but but hey if you're
like me and you rather bill your own
yeah hopefully I said you found this
somewhat helpful and if if so going
leave me a comment and yeah until next
time good luck saving the galaxy I'm
going to go home and get some sleep